[Musique]
le cas de la tht
je vais vous parlé d' autisme c'était
pas dans le titre
l'autisme on l'appelle aussi les
troubles du spectre de l'autisme
c'est un trouble de la communication et
des interactions sociales qui associe
aussi des intérêts restreints de manière
variable des rituels des gestes
stéréotypé ou des particularités
sensorielle il débute très tôt dans la
petite enfance et touchent à peu près 1%
la population française ça représente
plus de 600 mille personnes les enfants
avec otis deviennent des adultes au
destin variables certains vont vivre en
institution
mais d'autres vont être des artistes des
scientifiques des écrivains ils sont
passionnants ils partagent avec nous
leurs visions du monde et sont sûrs tedx
surtout temps peu loin d'une quand ils
ne peuvent pas témoigné leur famille
raconte par exemple il de claire est une
spécialiste de l'autisme
elle est aussi formatrice et maman d'un
jeune homme avec autisme avec lui elle a
appris la pensée autistique
elle a transmis son expérience dans des
colloques ou dans des livres
mon petit frère de la lune si vous avez
l'occasion de le voir c'est un bijou de
film d'animation
ça raconte une grande soeur en fête
raconte l'histoire de son petit frère en
famille elle l'observent elle le
comprend peu un peu et tu as qu elle
arrive à attirer son attention avec un
bijou est là elle nous dit avec mon
frère on a inventé un jeu alors là on
est tous les deux et c'est bien et c'est
bien dans le titre quand on est à 2
c'est un petit miracle dans la vie de la
famille ces témoignages
on un message commun les personnes avec
autisme quelque chose à nous dire
mais je ne suis pas là pour parler à
leur place
vous avez vu qu'il le faisait très bien
je suis pas là non plus pour vous dire
comment marcheurs et mal ou bien leur
cerveau alors je veux juste vous emmener
en promenade avec des personnes avec
autisme pour transformer votre regard
sur le handicap et ça ce serait pour moi
un petit miracle tedx on va voir à au
début un acte fondamental de la
communication et le pointage pour
partager son intérêt
regarde regarde ça pour attirer
l'attention
l'enfant pointe l'autre homme regarde
des bulles encore encore des bulles et
c'est la réciprocité social dans nos
interventions précoces on travaille très
tôt le pointage avec les enfants pour
leur apprendre à demander encore encore
plutôt que des cris mais aussi parce
qu'on pense que les personnes avec
autisme ont quelque chose d'important à
nous montrer regarde regarde ça la plage
la plage lucas à la maison est absorbée
par la sensation de l'eau sensation
sensation de lure qui coule sur ses
doigts à la plage il tourne le dos aux
autres enfants
il fixe intensément la vague
il cherche la ligne parfaite des cubes
entre l'eau et le sable il n'entend plus
ni les voix ni son prénom
la sensation bloc toutes les perceptions
il est concentré
des études avec autisme ont montré qu'il
y avait un problème de connectivité
neuronale ça entraîne des perceptions
des émotions ou même une vigilance trop
intense
ils sont aussi très sensibles aux
changements le monde est imprévisible
il faudrait pouvoir le ralentir ils
changent sans cesse il faudrait pouvoir
le dollar était pour le rendre
prédictible joanes femmes asperger m'a
écrit vite vite il faut fixer pour ne
pas oublier qu'il y avait un avant et
que ça existait mais à la plage
il y avait aussi maël huit ans maël son
intérêt à la plage c'est le sable elle
fait des trous bien alignées de si beaux
trous qu'elle impressionné tous les
autres enfants la plage et cette année
pour la première fois elle a pu associer
une petite fille à son intérêt
particulier ensemble elles ont creusé le
plus grand grand trou de la plage et ça
pour la famille cette première copine
c'était le petit miracle des vacances ah
oui les personnes avec autisme ont le
goût du détail dans notre jargon parce
qu'on a un petit jargon en neurosciences
ont dit qu'ils ont une tendance ou une
préférence pour le traitement local de
l'information en population générale
nous on a plutôt une préférence pour
traitement global
par exemple si on regarde cette image on
voit à l'endos ouais on n'est pas
spécialement attiré par des formes
géométriques qui le composent et le
traitement global ça nous sert aussi
beaucoup pour lire les expressions les
émotions sur le visage par exemple si je
me focalise sur un détail comme le
menton là c'est beaucoup plus difficile
de percevoir des expressions de mon
visage ou la variété
alors je disais les personnes avec
autisme ont une tendance au traitement
local de l'information c'est-à-dire
havre pour repérer les détails d'un
ensemble qui qui composent une forme
globale donc ils vont être avantagés
dans ce type
des preuves cognitives et pourtant je me
disais quand même dans la rue on croise
plus souvent des visages que des
triangles au quotidien et je me disais
vraiment comment transformer ce goût du
détail en avantage je ne savais pas en
tout cas pas dans le quotidien
jusqu'au jour où en balade dans le
queensland alors que j'admirais
l'immensité de la forêt tropicale
la beauté de la rivière un type non pas
un type en fait un jeune homme avec otis
nous interpelle look louga delattre où
il avait pas de pointer new look 1 watt
scarface
ouais il s'appelle scarface c'est un
mâle dominant de la rivière fait 450 kg
et c'est genre de détails croquant que
lui seul avait perçu une retour en
france
les personnes avec autisme aime bien
regarder les objets qui tournent les
plus grands aussi les plus petits c'est
une stimulation visuelle
d'autres encore préfèrent tourner sur
eux-mêmes comme ça encore et encore où
mettre la tête en bas il stimule leur
système labyrinthique et sébastien me
dit quand je vois la machine à laver
tournée je sais pas pourquoi ça me fait
du bien et nous non plus on sait pas
pourquoi et ça nous intrigue
alors on fait des études en imagerie
pour essayer de comprendre quelle zone
du cerveau s'active quand on regarde des
objets tournée et quelles zones du
cerveau s'active quand on regarde et
scène sociale comme des petites dames
qui font des comptines mais sébastien
lui il est un peu culpabilisé quand il
nous avoue son goût pour les machines à
laver alors il me précise mais tu sais
je le fais pas souvent alors moi je lui
dis mais t'inquiète pas sébastien
t'inquiète pas figure-toi qu'au musée
goma dans le queensland
une des installations qui a le plus de
succès c'est celle ci celle de lara
favaretto elle a installé des grosses
turbines ou des sorts de rouleaux pour
laver les voitures
elle les a pas
elle les fait tourner regarde regarde ça
sébastien je suis claire vous me suivez
assez sympa de tailler une bavette chez
tedx voyez cette petite expression
d'abord je suis pas clair ni sophie
comme dans le programme je suis sans
bride mais pour les personnes avec
autisme
ça peut être vite compliqué ce langage
ses expressions le langage ferg et
figuré on dit que dans l'autisme
ils ont une compréhension littérale du
langage c'est à dire qu'ils prennent les
mots au pied de la lettre et nous qu'est
ce qui nous permet finalement de ne pas
en prendre les mots auprès du bon pied
de la lettre ou une expression comme à
c'est du joli ça trois choses notre
expérience sociale bien sûr la mimique
et l'intonation aa et le contexte août
je viens de faire une bêtise trois
domaines dans lesquels les personnes
autistes vont être en difficulté alors
comme médecin comme je suis censé
normalement fournir une information
claire et intelligible pour toutes les
personnes
j'ai appris face à des personnes qui
maîtrisent pas le français comme autiste
ou pas d'ailleurs à éviter le jargon
trop médical ou utiliser des supports
imagé mais surtout a demandé à mon
interlocuteur s'il m'avait comprise je
suis claire bon c'était ma blague
[Musique]
donc voila et tout ça je le fais parce
que ce sont les personnes avec autisme
qui me l'ont appris
les relations sociales bon c'est
compliqué pour tout le monde
on manifeste on ce tweet mais il paraît
même si c'est compliqué que pour
résoudre une question complexe
on serait meilleur à plusieurs ça c'est
grâce à notre intelligence sociale elle
est porté en partie par notre empathie
mais aussi notre capacité à nous mettre
à la place des autres ou à nous avoir
une représentation de leur état d'esprit
on appelle ça la théorie de l'esprit
alors ces compétences sont répartis de
manière très inégale dans la pop
la scion est parmi les moins favorisés
il est vrai qu'on trouve des personnes
avec autisme
donc nous on a créé des groupes
d'habiletés sociales et dans ces groupes
on va essayer de transmettre de
compétences par exemple une scène de
l'école on va dire mais franchement il
faut que tu arrêtes de rappeler sans
cesse des règles de la classe à des
copains qui mène le foutoir parce qu
après l'école il ya la sortie de l'école
ou alors on essaye de les convaincre
pour un entretien d'embauché mais non
ventées qualité de valoriser c'est
absolument ni manipuler ni mentir ils
sont pas convaincus et puis quand ils
sont en stage on assiste un peu si tu
veux vraiment intégré il faut que tu
t'arrêtes intéresse un peu aux vacances
de ton collègue mais ça nan nan c'est
pas du tout de l'hypocrisie c'est un peu
d'empathie mais bon ils doivent faire
tout ça et en plus au bon moment c'est à
dire qu'on s'intéresse pas aux vacances
de son collègue
alors qu'ils viennent des cd ou feint
pas dupe à lui mais quelqu'un de sa
famille ouais enfin bon tout est
possible c'est des grandes vacances les
décès alors revenons aux relations
sociales donc il doit faire ça et nous
on a trouvé que c'était très très long
dossier de leur transmettre nos défauts
enfin je veux dire nos compétences
sociales
donc on a décidé de travailler sur leurs
qualités et des qualités on en a vu on a
vu nous leur motivation quand il
s'intéresse à un sujet genre
les fractales la gastronomie ils peuvent
accumuler un nom
voilà merci en fait tout ça est prévu
vous inquiétez pas donc on a vu leurs
motivations concernant de nombreux
sujets et leur capacité à accumuler des
connaissances plus important il ne lâche
jamais une question non résolue ce qu'on
a vu aussi c'est leur incroyable
créativité des dessins magnifiques
grâce aussi à leurs particularités
sensorielles ou leur regard unique sur
le monde dans nos groupes de travail
parce qu'ils y participent
on a apprécié leur précision grâce à
leur goût du détail
et puis dans les groupes de travail au
ministère quand il faut travailler sur
des recommandations
on apprécie vraiment leur rigueur de
langage leur style de communication très
direct enfin plus que tout on les a vus
affronter leurs difficultés sociales et
il s'accroche malgré le harcèlement la
solitude ou même parfois l' angoisse
enfin on a pu apprécier leur à loyauté
et tout ça tout ça je les ai vus parce
qu'ils me l'ont montré regarde regarde
ça alors si vous croisez sur votre
chemin des personnes avec autisme osé la
rencontre merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]